hey this is very very interesting i
finally was able to get on truth social
truth social is the uh trumpian social
media platform that trump seems unable
to pronounce correctly truth essential
exactly truth central i finally was able
to get on truth social because they now
you can just sign up on a desktop
computer you don't need to have a
particular phone now to do it
so you can find me on truth social at
dpakman i'm just trolling on there i'll
probably get banned
but
i realized when looking around
that on election day tuesday before and
after the election
failed former president donald trump was
engaged in just a dystopian
authoritarian series of screeds and
posts i don't know what they don't call
them tweets because it's not twitter
although they basically copied twitter
to design this site
check out the stuff that donald trump
was posting um throughout the day and
then after so trump posting remember all
three candidates in pennsylvania were
ultra maga so what trump was doing there
was hedging his endorsement trump
endorsed mem at oz and we still don't
know who actually won that primary but
trump was trying to basically say
whether it's dave mccormick or kathy
barnett or memit oz it's all a win for
trump because they're all ultra mega so
that was trump hedging earlier in the
day
but then here's the really scary post
as has happened before in other
elections including with donald trump's
in 2020
we didn't have the results around 11 pm
or midnight eastern on election day and
donald trump posted to troth central
quote dr oz should declare victory it
makes it much harder for them to cheat
with the ballots that they quote just
happen to find end trump's quote and end
full quote
that's an authoritarian nightmare and
that is exactly you know when we go back
to trump coming out at 2am on election
day in november of 2020 and saying we
won when he very clearly hadn't won it
wasn't clear he lost but it was very
clear he hadn't yet won
he's admitting what the game is here you
say you won you just take credit for it
and it makes it harder than it poisons
the well where people say i don't know i
mean he claimed victory he must have won
trump then attacking fox news saying fox
news had a really bad night they were
way off on the count in timing in the oz
vote anybody watching would have said it
was over when actually it was just the
opposite i assume the coverage was being
led by the same guy that called arizona
who believe it or not they brought back
i want his agent now of course trump
continues to insist that he actually won
arizona it is not true joe biden won
arizona joe biden won arizona uh by any
measure of how you count ballots and
trump continues to lie about that
and then trump posting another one of
these truths which are actually lies
quite kafka-esque quote the fake news
media is having a really time really
hard time saying that magga and trump
didn't have anything but a spectacular
evening of voting and winning hold on
the best is yet to come now of course uh
madison cawthorne lost after just 16
months in office some trumpists won some
trumpist loss but understand that the
game is
endorse mostly people who we know are
going to win with or without trump's
endorsement and then take credit for it
it is a nightmare on truth social if
you're curious it's sort of masochistic
i get it but if you're curious i'm on
there at least until they ban me uh i'm
deep hackman on truth truth truth
essential yeah exactly we'll take a
quick break and be right back after this
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor i'm thrilled about
because i sleep on a helix mattress at
home and it's just the perfect mattress
one of the best things about helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type your sleeping position your
back pain issues you might have and they
will pair you with a mattress that will
be perfect for you i took the sleep quiz
the mattress they suggested was exactly
what i needed i often get too hot at
night the mattress keeps me cool it's
not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right and i've just been
getting way better sleep you only buy a
mattress every decade or so
don't get stuck with something that's
not perfect for you and all helix
mattresses come with a 10 year warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within a hundred days if you
don't love it but i think you will for a
limited time helix is offering up to 350
off all mattress orders plus two free
pillows at
helixsleep.com
pacman it's the biggest discount they've
ever offered the link is down below